[Musique]
les fauchés chez fauchon 150 à 200
chômeurs des jeunes communistes ont
envahi cet après-midi la célèbre
épicerie parisienne l'un des fleurons du
luxe de la capitale la direction a
appelé la police qui a fait évacuer les
lieux une dizaine de personnes ont été
interpellées anne-marie gourrier
plus d'une centaine de jeunes chômeurs
et des membres des jeunesses communistes
ont occupé samedi en début d'après-midi
la célèbre épicerie de luxe fauchon
place de la madeleine
après s'être servis dans le magasin les
jeunes ont présenté ou vendeuses des
bons d'achat factice
chauffeur s'en est occupé ce magasin
trouver des bouteilles de digestif
1200000 la pièce il y a dans ce pays des
gens qui n'ont rien absolument il ya
pour mir pour passer les fêtes et
d'autres qui comme tous les os x accents
délices en d2
un luxe insolent les manifestants ont
été délogés par la police violemment
selon le en fin d'après-midi réouverture
des magasins tout rentrait dans l'ordre
[Musique]